Так на Чернігівщині готуються оборонятися від ворога.
Військовий Олег проводить нас сотнями метрів
виритих у полі траншей.
Чим більше поворотів таких, тим більше спасіння.
Осколки менше летять. За рахунок поворотів:
ти забігаєш за поворот - заховався,
забігаєш - заховався. Відстрілявся - перебіг.
Чим більше позицій, тим більше живемо.
Знадобляться - не знадобляться, будемо працювати,
ми - за Україну, слава Україні!
Більшість цих споруд копали полкові землерийні машини.
А рівняють і підчищають вручну.
До таких робіт залучають місцевих безробітних.
Для цього уряд запровадив спеціальну програму - "Армію відновлення".
Сергій - один із її "бійців".
Оце робив сходи я. До сходів усе було отак.
Не я один. Усе ми копали, три метри вниз.
Один викидає, другий копає.
Попри товариську атмосферу і корисну для регіону роботу,
чоловік сумує за своєю професією.
Він родом з Чернігівщини, але все життя прожив у Дружківці на Донеччині.
За своїм фахом 56-річний чоловік не може знайти роботу.
Токар-розточувальник на Дружківському машинобудівному заводі.
Усе життя після служби в армії. Шахтне обладнання завод виготовляв.
Якусь частину з шахтного обладнання виготовляв я.
І станок подобався, і робота подобалася, і колектив.
Після того, як почалася війна, усі як зникли.
Сергій просився до місцевої тероборони, але не взяли.
Тому вже другий місяць він допомагає військовим, як може.
Інші безробітні разом з електриками розчищають гілля.
59-річний Василь у минулому працював на залізниці,
потім - охоронцем. Роботу втратив ще до війни.
Подумки чоловік із сином, який воює під Бахмутом.
Він пішов добровольцем, і я його розумію.
Він вважав це потрібним і правильним.
І я його рішення підтримав, хоч і в думках, але підтримав.
Тому що я його батько і, як сказати…
Сподіваюся, що він живий і з перемогою прийде додому.
Я пішов на ці роботи, бо треба і місту допомогти по благоустрою,
і, думаю, ми і нашим дітям теж допоможемо, які на війні.
Така ж мотивація і в 24-річного Єгора.
Хоча б якусь користь приносимо місту,
бо хлопці зараз там на передовій,
а ми хоча б тут щось робимо для нашого міста, щоб чисто було.
Хлопці захищають, а ми зачищаємо місто, можна так сказати.
У хлопця - молода дружина і дев'ятимісячний малюк.
Через війну м'ясокомбінат, де він працював,
скоротив штат. Під скорочення потрапив і Єгор.
Багато де на виробництвах поскорочувалися місця.
Багато де критерії дуже високі треба.
У мене незакінчена [освіта], у мене тільки 11 класів.
Спеціальної немає, не закінчував.
Працював то вантажником, то підсобним робітником.
Зараз дуже складно знайти, тому що зараз хто міг, вакансії вже позаймали.
Поки перебиваємося тим, що є. І те теж гарно.
До суспільно-корисних робіт за урядовою "Армією відновлення"
безробітних залучають місцеві центри зайнятості.
Тим, хто стоїть на обліку, пропонують роботи,
на які є запит від комунальних чи бюджетних підприємств:
розбирати завали, заготовляти дрова, укріплювати дамби, чистити узбіччя.
Це здебільшого фізично складні роботи.
Тож для жінок можливостей небагато.
Хоча серед безробітних їх більше, ніж чоловіків.
Для жінок такої роботи немає, крім підготовки оцих цивільних споруд
- підвалів для укриттів. Там була робота для жінок.
Прибирання, білили стіни. Ну і плетіння сіток.
Зарплата - 6700 гривень. Вона вища, ніж середні виплати
за безробіттям - на Чернігівщині це трохи більше чотирьох тисяч гривень.
Тоді як в міністерстві економіки наголошують,
що працевлаштування на суспільно-корисні роботи добровільне,
у Чернігівському обласному центрі зайнятості пояснюють, що це не зовсім так.
Якщо безробітні відмовляються від запропонованих робіт,
то їх знімають з обліку. Відповідно й виплат вони отримувати не будуть.
Якщо цей чоловік відмовляється, ви бачили цих чоловіків -
здорових, нормальних чоловіків, вони з якоїсь причини ж не служать в армії,
то хай працюють в "Армії відродження", я так розумію.
Були такі, що відмовлялися, кажуть мені спеціалісти,
але після роз'яснення вони погодилися.
Окрім Чернігівщини програма працює також на Сумщині, Полтавщині,
Донеччині, Київщині, Рівненщині.
Загалом же "Армія відновлення" поки нагадує радше полк.
По Україні до неї долучені наразі лише 1054 особи.
Тоді як усього безробітних, за даними мінекономіки,
близько двох з половиною мільйонів.
У центрах зайнятості зареєстровані 225 тисяч осіб.
Навряд чи ми зможемо залучити всіх до цих робіт,
але ми виходимо тут з бюджету і ми розуміємо,
що загальний обсяг фінансування цих робіт становить в цьому році 20 мільйонів гривень
і сьогодні ми профінансували таких робіт
на майже 5 мільйонів гривень. Тому ми розуміємо,
що найперше - це потреба, яка потреба буде оголошена.
Крім того в уряді визнають: "Армія відновлення" -
це лише один із механізмів боротьби з безробіттям
-  поруч із грантовими програмами для підприємств
і стимулами для бізнесу працевлаштовувати безробітних.
Водночас наступного року розраховують,
що без роботи можуть залишитися ще більше
- до 2,8 мільйона людей.